welcome to this video playing Wow
shushing hi w-wait playing a double
fianchetto pretty interesting flank
opening that I click many times in the
tournament chess oh this looks like it
probably weren't supposed to a
symmetrical English or this kind of
position let's same position type yeah
and I like to keep the pieces on not
trade too much
what's ideas to put a knight on d5 2293
d5 something like that quick too yeah
maybe it's going for 27 enter no okay
should I play on 93 be 93 25mm that
should be should be too awful
yeah what should black do now yeah can
you play be five or is this insane maybe
it is interesting
Bishop to h6 and yeah it is a pin what
can you do therefore or is this is this
to weakening yeah hard to do without it
really at least had controlled some e
five yeah not sure that this is really
great
now this looks better in yeah but if I
take in this way and play Bob deform
where's your queen going and where are
all your pieces going looks it looks a
bit a bit strange
where is there some big technical idea
and night before I think I can just play
Bishop c4 a bishops night c4 of course
and I don't see how he how we protect
this piece queen f2 and I don't
understand it come on let's not spend
too much time and at the end lose on
time yeah I think I just win this piece
I mean queen bee 5a for quincy 554 ID
cards the piece is gone and takes e4
with Roxy for and and and it's also
basically over
now maybe you can maybe you can sec and
play and play Knight to g4 while this
will be sick okay so but I can play this
one
probably I must play this one
Bishop d4 queen d4 Knight f2 King g1 he
cannot take d 1 because the queen is
saying so it should keep should keep the
material advantage there's still all
kinds of stuff hanging before and so on
yep but the night is strapped can go
here and trap it right
okay really this is disappointing okay
then let's take you seven so also not
bad but he gets this slide come to play
let's grab space um this is better not
waste time with taking you 74 should
have three and king king in the middle
yeah this is better just get you get
your pieces on inflamed
I is a ticking b3 what the heck what the
heck am i doing I need to need to cover
this
ok
attending to be too
and taking b5
well I really did everything to make it
complicated I mean so just take it on be
54 yeah come on simplify this a bit
check
this is the easiest I think the two
points are too much the king is just too
far away preparing Kings is seven he's
gotta move I think King c7 and wins
black result yeah I really I really loud
so much here from this from this winning
position yeah bishop default was also
winning but this should have been really
easy bruxism Roxy too yeah I of course
Roxy two and then it's trapped not this
one Roxy to just Roxy too yeah now he's
got no tempo move like b5 and this is
just trapped how silly is this and then
it really got tricky don't know maybe
maybe he really had something oh it's
very much possible it's still some
better it's a silly exchange but it was
it was very shaky how I played this yeah
here probably it's everything's back in
order and this is Winningham this is too
much the space advantage to the pond and
the e5 or the suppression yeah an
interesting game but I real ow allowed I
allowed far too much thanks for watching